maybe these guys were maybe the people
who are drawn to those sports are the
ones that are you know or drawn to be
elite in those sports already had a
genetic predisposition that's sort of my
feeling is it's Lance Armstrong fight
doesn't have a very large heart I don't
know I think what Lance had that was
pretty unique even amongst the world's
best which is what he competed with of
course I think his lactate threshold was
a lot higher than most people
genetically yeah and then of course in a
in again you know I mean I know it's
such a controversial topic although my
view is I think that every single
cyclist at least from 1991 until 2011
was on highly highly you know augmented
programs so you know that Lance won
seven of those years in the in that
context just tells me that he was you
know training harder and being more
specific to the race I mean what people
don't understand is like I mean Lance
only peaked for one race a year like
everything that that team US Postal did
was geared for that one race and also
when you really look at how much doping
they did it well she wasn't that much
like you know when they were blood
transfusing it might have been two units
over the course of a race and I'm not
saying that that wouldn't help it would
help a lot but that's nothing compared
to what people were doing just a few
years before Lance came along
so Lance won I think his first one in 99
the guy who won before that in 98 was
Marco Pantani before that was again
Ayano Rick in 97 and before that was
gonna be Horne Reese Bjorn Reese's
nickname was mr. 60 because his
hematocrit was always over 60 that's
frickin state like how that guy didn't
die of a stroke I don't know is that for
me P oh yeah Lance never had a crit over
50 to my knowledge they would basically
always titrate with Ipoh and or
hemoglobin up to 50 which was the
trigger so you know but but I think and
again i i've never i don't know lance at
all so i certainly don't know anything
about him beyond like the little bits
that i have read over time but i do
think his lactate tolerance was
remarkable meaning
you know we measure lactate in athletes
swimmers and cyclists when they're you
know trying to figure out what their
performance is and as far as I can tell
there are seem to be these two
phenotypes there's the one phenotype
where people can tolerate staggeringly
high amounts of lactate and and again
it's not lactate per se that is causing
the pain that you're experiencing it's
the hydrogen ion that accompanies the
lactate so lactic acid the acid part of
that is the hydrogen ion and that's
actually what's poisoning the muscle and
preventing the muscle from having this
effortless actin-myosin
act you know contract release etcetera
but we use lactate as a proxy because
where lactate is high the hydrogen ion
is high and there are some people who
can just tolerate like incredible doses
I used to work with Olympic swimmers and
I mean there were just a couple of these
guys like they could actually be
standing with a lactate of 24 I mean
when I was competing if I had a lactate
above 16 or 17 I couldn't be standing
like that was just too much pain like I
was on the floor if I was over 17 I was
puking and and I saw dudes that could
stand there at 24 in fact I one of my
good friends he won a gold and a silver
medal in the Sydney Olympics and retired
from swimming in 2004 then came back to
swim masters so and was like he actually
was trying to make a comeback to make
the 2012 Olympic team and when he was
training for that like I would poke him
between races and I saw him get out of a
400 into the individual medley race
which is the hardest swim race of them
all the 400 IM is i mean you might as
well just shoot yourself it's so painful
he got out of that had a lactate of
eighteen two minutes later not two
minutes later maybe seven mins later
jumped on the blocks and won a hundred
breasts race you know came out with a
lactate of 21 that kind of thing so
there are those guys and then I think at
the other end of the spectrum the word
on the street is guys like Michael
Phelps or at the opposite end of that
where they are so efficient at shuttling
lactic acid out of the cell back to the
liver where this thing called the Cori
cycle actually turns lactate back into
glucose that they never have high levels
of lactate now again all of this is sort
of work you know speculation because I
don't I think they were very hush-hush
about Phelps his number
but I heard from reliable and reasonable
sources that he would rarely have a
lactate above 8.0 including when he's
breaking World Records whoa which for me
at 8.0 like I'm smoking and joking like
that's fine but for you know he was so
efficient at getting rid of it that yeah
he could you know set the world record
in the 400 I am and have a lactate of
eight again I don't know if this is true
but but I've mantilla plausible
mechanism by which it could be well it's
fascinating that this could potentially
all be engineered right that like
through use of CRISPR or something else
you could take all these various facets
of performance enhancing modalities
extend a person's ability in so many
different ways and create a super person
yeah of course it's interesting right
once you start genetically doing it good
does it become cheating in the same way
like would we would we does it if you
have someone like Phelps who has this
genetic predisposition to getting rid of
lactose lactate and you take someone
like me who probably has none of that
and you know you juice me up to his
level is that cheating I mean I don't
know I mean those are the questions I
mean this is why people like Daniel
Coyle who are so critical of Lance
Armstrong say because because on the one
hand you'll have camps that say look
it's the great equalizer like why don't
we just let everybody dope and that's a
steroid argument with them amazed well
well and and frankly it's more my
argument but if I have a different
reason for arguing that way which is I
think having done these sports and
nowhere near at the high level that
those guys do it I just know how
destructive they are like the Tour de
France is the most unhealthy thing on
the face of the earth I've heard that
it's healthier to do two Tour de France
on steroids than it is to do it off
sterile abso-fucking-lutely when those
guys finish the Tour de France they are
osteopenic I mean their bone density has
eroded their muscle they have lost so
much muscle mass I mean it is a
devastating grueling event now nothing's
going to completely ameliorate that but
like if we think that like watching
these guys kill themselves riding six
hours a day hitting peak thresholds of
you know six watts per kilogram if we
think there's anything physiologically
reasonable about that we're out to
[ __ ] lunch but is that the point I
mean is
the point is that you can push your mind
to do something your body absolutely
doesn't want to do so you should be
rewarded for for that you know and and
these guys are in a league of their own
I mean professional cyclists are some of
the toughest athletes out there I mean
obviously every athlete at the peak of
their game is remarkable and and no
disrespect to like the best running back
in the NFL but like you can't even
compare that to what a guy does for
workload for sure yeah for just the pain
like the absolute sheer discomfort and
the physiologic torture and the duration
of it and all these other things well
you see it in their faces too those guys
like when they retired they look like
they're 10 years older than they are
yeah yeah yeah I mean they've lost all
of the fat a lot of them you know they
just if you don't have fat in your face
I mean you age yeah matically they just
look exhausted too I mean it looks like
it's just drained them like they've
forced to live 30 years inside of ten
yeah so it's like what if we just say
guess what everybody's allowed to use
whatever amounts of EPO blood
testosterone to be at the 80th
percentile of what we consider normal so
everybody's allowed to walk around with
a hemoglobin of 14.7 or up to 14 point 7
or 50 would sheet that right wouldn't
they I mean if you allow people to use
but but I also think like the the
testing on this stuff is so like it's so
JV now there was this idea called the
biological passport then was introduced
many years ago which basically said look
we're gonna develop a signature for
every person and now if you deviate much
from your signature we'll that'll be the
trigger and the argument again by
certain people I think Daniel Coyle
argued this a lot in one of his books
that he wrote ripping apart lance was
the reason it's that the reason doping
is unfair because that everybody does it
argument doesn't hold water is because
if you're a person who naturally lives
at a hematocrit of 47 you're only
getting a slight improvement going from
47 to 50 if you're a person who
naturally lives at 43 you going from 43
to 50 you get a much bigger advantage to
which I say yeah but that's true on a
relative basis but an absolute level if
everybody's walking around with a
hematocrit of 48 to 50 they'd still have
the same oxygen
carrying capacity it does level the
playing field the concern though isn't
oh I would believe the concern is you
don't want people to think that the only
way to do this sport is to take drugs